find the people who value what you have
the most there's a father who gifts his
son an old beat up car hey I don't know
if it drives or not but you can take it
down to the dealership down the street
see if you can trade and get some money
so he goes down the street goes to the
dealership they say we'll give you a
thousand bucks for it comes back home
he's like Dad they say give me a
thousand bucks he's like okay go to the
impound yard goes there I don't know
this might be 500 bucks of metal comes
back home he's like Dad you know he said
it was gonna be 500 he's like hey go
down the street to that antique
dealership see if they've got anything
so he goes down there talks to the guy
comes back home super excited he's like
Dad you won't believe it he's like this
is a historic car there's only like 10
of them left gets worth a hundred
thousand dollars father smiles and he's
like and the lesson I want you to know
is that it's not necessarily who you are
but the people that value you the most